[Musica]
nella storia della vita di ciascuno di
noi
nella storia della vita
esistono anni che consideriamo
memorabili pensateci
pensate ai vostri anni immemorabile
molto probabilmente li visualizzate nel
loro della loro numerica e ricordate
perché quegli anni sono memorabili
il mio primo anno memorabile e il 1977
era un bambino di mirafiori sud con gli
amici del palazzo questo palazzo con gli
amici del cortile con gli amici del dei
giardinetti
oggi sono un torinese immigrato sono un
neo milanese e fortunatamente molti
degli amici del 1977 sono ancora i miei
amici oggi il 1977 e un anno per me
memorabile per due motivi principali il
primo motivo perché mio padre un giorno
mi chiama e mi dice ivan vieni ti porto
allo stadio andiamo a festeggiare la
coppa uefa
era la mia prima volta allo stadio
ricordo perfettamente la scalinata dello
stadio comunale la luce del sole che
passava attraverso gli striscioni e
l'odore dell'erba arrivato alla fine
della scalinata a quel giorno è nata una
passione che mi accompagna ogni singolo
giorno della mia vita
il secondo motivo per il quale il 1977 e
un anno per me meno morale e perché un
giorno di novembre
mio nonno mi chiama e mi dice ivan viene
oggi ti porto al cinema ti porta al
cinema ideal a vedere guerre stellari
a quel tempo non c'era uno due tre
quattro episodi era guerre stellari
e a quel tempo al cinema si poteva
rimanere quanto si voleva quindi sono
andato con mio nonno allo spettacolo
delle 2 10 all'ideal e sono rimasto
dentro per tre proiezioni consecutive
sono arrivato a casa mia non ovviamente
molto arrabbiata verso le otto e mezzo
e quel giorno mi è nata una passione per
il cinema per la tecnologia e per
l'innovazione che nel corso degli anni
sono riuscito a far diventare anche la
mia professione
c'è una frase in quel film che mi torna
sempre in mente in questo periodo e
voglio condividerla con voi se non ha
bisogno di me signore io mi spegnerei
per un po
pensateci la vera differenza fra noi
esseri di carbonio gli esseri umani e
gli esseri oggi di felice che chiamiamo
robot e intelligenza artificiale è
questa noi non possiamo spegnersi
non possiamo spegnerci un po noi non ci
spieghiamo neanche quando dormiamo loro
si possono spegnere e si possono
riaccendere diciamo se dobbiamo
progettare il futuro delle relazioni fra
noi e le macchine dobbiamo garantirci
che questa piccola differenza risulti
essere il nostro grande vantaggio
possiamo poter spegnere le macchine e
voler spegnere le macchine attenzione è
molto difficile
già oggi se pensate alla vostra vita
quotidiana vi è difficile pensare di
poter spegnere le macchine e questo sarà
sempre più difficile
sempre con maggiore difficoltà noi
avremo quel piccolo vantaggio messo in
difficoltà perché perché la tecnologia
che sta arrivando è quella che già oggi
utilizziamo e che abbiamo in tasca non è
solo una tecnologia abilità trici non ci
consente solo di abbassare la soglia
della fatica mentale o fisica non ci
consente di accorciare le distanze non
ci consente di avere strumenti di
condivisione di conoscenza e ovviamente
di comunicazione sempre più rapidi
no la tecnologia che sta arrivando è una
tecnologia che andrà a estendere le
nostre capacità cognitive
avremo la possibilità di pensare meglio
avremo la possibilità di abbassare la
percentuale dei nostri errori
soglia dell'errore di quello che
pensiamo di quello che facciamo
avremo la possibilità di estendere le
nostre capacità cognitive e di essere
degli esseri umani
potenziati e vi faccio vedere un piccolo
esempio
questa in apparenza è un ristorante
robotizzato vedete ci sono dei robot che
passano in mezzo ai tavoli e prendono le
comande e portano ovviamente le comande
ai tavoli ma festi non sono dei robot
queste sono interfaccia dietro ogni
singolo robot c'è un nostro diciamo con
simile c'è un essere umano allettato
tetraplegico che grazie a questo robot
riesce ad avere un modello di relazione
riesce a uscire fuori dall'ospedale e
riesce ad avere un lavoro remunerato
questo è un esperimento dell'ultima
l'ultima edizione della fiera della
robotica di tokyo è un esperimento per
raccogliere fondi di beneficenza che è
andato molto bene e già si pensa di
industrializzare sul territorio
e se ci pensate questo esperimento è
molto diverso dall altro esperimento
famoso giapponese dell'hotel robotizzato
in cui le macchine sostituivano l'uomo
questo è un esempio di mondo ibrido e
noi dobbiamo abituarci al mondo ibrido
perché il combinato disposto della
nostra essenza di esseri umani e le auto
automatiche piuttosto che le macchine
non avviene solo per transumanesimo e
quindi con la possibilità di metterci
della tecnologia dentro piuttosto che di
sostituzione il mondo ibrido è un mondo
che ci apre a nuove opportunità nuove
sfide nuovi problemi
un nuovo modo di intendere la realtà che
ci circonda
dobbiamo essere pronti a questo mondo
ibrido perché attenzione nel mondo
ibrido il mantra degli ultimi anni che
ci ha contraddistinto del nostro modo di
pensare
ovvero less is more viene completamente
ribaltato mor is less e quello che avrà
la capacità di contraddistinguere il
nostro futuro prossimo ovvero più noi
creeremo spazi di ibridazione più avremo
meno differenze meno problemi meno
diseguaglianza questo vuol dire che non
è un fatto tecnologico che dovremmo
combinare tecnologia competenze
informazioni e ovviamente comportamenti
umani in maniera molto diversa
so benissimo che state pensando che ci
sono dei meno fortemente negativi meno
privacy
meno controlli meno trasparenza meno
lavoro meno posti di lavoro ma queste
sfide noi riusciremo a vincerle se
aumentiamo competenze analisi studi
profondità di pensiero creatività più
noi aggiungeremo queste caratteristiche
più noi saremo in grado di vincere
queste nuove sfide perché il mondo
dell'ibridazione non è un mondo fatto di
contrapposizioni di differenze di
verticalità e un mondo che è fatto di
integrazione e di potenziamenti e quando
pensiamo ai potenziamenti dobbiamo
pensare anche a combinare cose che in
qualche modo ci sembrano in
contrapposizione in modo completamente
dovremo potenziare il modo di vedere la
realtà fra real e simulato non è una
contrapposizione fra ciò che sembra
essere ciò che dovremmo essere in grado
di potenziare di combinare l'individuale
con il collettivo perché la somma degli
interessi degli individui non
necessariamente farà l'interesse della
collettività e la somma degli interessi
delle collettività non necessariamente
farà l'interesse globale perché avremo
un elemento con cui ci dovremo
confrontare che quello dell'intelligenza
collettiva che sarà potenziata dalla
tecnologia che avremo è insostenibile
utile sarà il combinato disposto tale
per cui la sostenibilità economica
ambientale e sociale determinerà un
utile che fortemente dovremo utilizzare
per reimpiegare questa sostenibilità
perché solo così riusciremo a ottenere
eguaglianza e inclusione e infine
dovremo capire che come sempre stato
nella storia dell'uomo
la morale strettamente correlata al
contesto tecnologico che viviamo se il
contesto tecnologico che vi diamo
viaggerà a velocità sempre su più
sostenute ciò che è morale sostanziale
dovremo interpretarla in maniera molto
rapida cercando di capire quali sono gli
effetti del mondo ibrido su quello che
sta succedendo
magari state pensando che il mondo
ibrido e di difficile interpretazione e
vi do quattro chiavi di lettura del
mondo ibrido la prima chiave di lettura
saranno le esternalità dovremmo pensare
alle conseguenze in maniera
completamente diversa
le esternalità saranno ciò che ci
consentiranno di capire l'utilità del
mondo di grido ciò che collega per
esempio l'auto robotica a stampa 3d di
organi umani
quello che collega l'aumentare dei
device tecnologici allo smaltimento dei
device tecnologici sicuramente qualcuno
di voi ha visto wally quello che collega
le nuove proteine le nuove carni
ad esempio alle emissioni di co2
l'accessibilità sarà l'unica chiave per
poter ottenere un equità sociale
l'accessibilità al mondo ibrido sarà
l'unico elemento che ci consentirà di
distribuire i vantaggi nel mondo ibrido
le rappresentanza intese come la
rappresentanza sociale ma inteso anche
come l'espressione dei famosi interessi
dell'individuo del collettivo dovranno
trovare nuove forme perché insieme a una
rappresentanza dei diritti dell'uomo e
della dei doveri dell'uomo
dovremo pensare anche alla
rappresentanza di quelle che sono le
macchine e quindi dovremo iniziare a
ragionare per empatia
chiamiamola umana e per empatia
artificiale e in ultimo la
redistribuzione sarà una chiave
fondamentale ma non era e distribuzione
di reddito o di ricchezza o meglio non è
solo quello è una redistribuzione degli
spazi che ci circondano e una
redistribuzione dei tempi della nostra
vita e una redistribuzione dei cicli di
vita delle nostre aziende
ma non dobbiamo preoccuparci perché è
già successo ed è sempre successo nella
storia dell'uomo perché noi abbiamo
geneticamente la capacità di trascendere
trascendere come il senso participio
presente del verbo latino trascendere
quindi siamo degli esseri trascendenti
abbiamo la possibilità di essere donne e
uomini che vanno oltre i limiti che
vanno oltre quello che conosciamo quindi
il mondo l'ibrido è un mondo per gli
irrequieti per coloro che vedo nei
limiti e vanno oltre i limiti per coloro
che andranno oltre il limite della
differenza fra fisico e virtuale
la differenza fa il digitale e
l'analogico la differenza e oltre il
limite del pensiero comune oltre il
limite del si stava meglio quando si
stava peggio perché solo così daremo
seguito al progressivo progresso
dell'uomo
solo così riusciremo ancora una volta a
essere esseri umani migliori esseri
umani potenziati e quindi sempre più
umani grazie torino
[Applauso]